a huge hearing up on Capitol Hill over
the alarming Rays rise rather of
artificial intelligence lots of folks
worried the technology could put us all
out of a job even destroy Humanity as we
know it even the guy behind chat GPT San
Altman is sounding the alarm before
Congress
my worst fears are that we cause
significant we the field the technology
the industry caused significant harm to
the world I think if this technology
goes wrong it can go quite wrong and we
want to be vocal about that we want to
work with the government to prevent that
from happening
he's putting the guy behind him to sleep
uh so what what do you what do you think
you know it's funny I asked the soul my
17 year old uh what she thinks about
this she says dad you can't even open
your Apple TV yeah and you should be
more worried about your Twitter than
this you know uh do you harness it do
you go with it do you drink it do you
control it people are doing it now
they're harnessing it they're using it
I'm either we're just talking about it
during the break
um but the problem is uh that it can
initially it was sold as something that
could take whatever is available and
summarize it okay now or create
something based upon what's available
now we're reading that researchers are
now seeing signs that AI can use human
reasoning that it was not programmed
with and if it can engage in human
reasoning then you know we're in trouble
and that's why you know they wouldn't be
doing this if they weren't worried about
some dereliction and not just in terms
of the criminal responsibility of
someone you know taking your identity or
stealing your voice and all that they're
worried about something bigger than that
bigger than plagiarism uh and his
biggest fear of it going wrong uh you
think about the world players everyone
who's got this and has it available how
can we conquer China how can they
conquer us what are we going to do if
they do this what do we do scary Tom
Hanks among many actors fears that uh
his uh his work will live on past the
grave his time
I could get together and pitch
a series of seven movies
that would star me in them in which I
would be
32 years old
from now until Kingdom Come I could be
hit by a bus tomorrow and that's it but
my performances can go on and on and on
and on and on
so Jesse there could be Waters beyond
the grave I mean if I'm already on it my
agent's paper to deal with Fox that
you're never gonna not see me again 100
years from now I'm going to be sitting
here making the same stupid arguments
the same bad analogies and glancing
sideways at whoever's sitting there this
time it happens to be you I don't care
about this thing at all I'm not worried
about it I said that about covid turned
out I was right
human beings especially men are
interested in sex power and resources
you can't have a machine be interested
in those three things our motivations
are completely different AI is not
interested in having sex there is no
status when it comes to robots and
resources what resources are they going
to use they don't need water and they
don't need food it's a totally different
phenomenon and again you're going to see
me forever whether you like it or not I
have a hundred year deal here at Fox Now
past the grave but it is inevitable it
is it isn't it well I don't know what
Jesse just made me feel a lot better
about everything thank you I actually am
fairly a techno Optimist I'm also a
realist I do think that the job loss
that is to come will be real it's like
taking the Industrial Revolution in all
the decades it took to get to to the end
of that now we're in the fourth
Revolution and you're going to see that
shrunk in just several years so there's
a lot of disruption but with disruption
comes competition and Innovation so I'm
excited about the things that could come
I I also don't think that Washington DC
is going to be able to actually create a
new law that will deal with this I do
think they should take a look at the
laws that are already on the books if
they think there are things that they
can and should do now they should do
that because by the time this Congress
gets around to regulating AI we'll be on
to the fifth industrial River well
Kamala is the aisr remember
you know what she'll be for the next 100
years no no Terminator
listen
children
it's too late yes they're already we all
whenever they go to the American people
someone said oops it's too late ai's
already going where it's going and yes
Jesse they don't want to have sex but
you know what they want to have no
errors if you're genetically flawed if
you what the the AI considers a
liability there'll be no feelings that's
why I'm excited about it it'll be facts
it'll just be you know what we're going
to keep 10 of the best and brightest
Jesse I think you're in there I think
you're in there wow that's the rest of
us it's the rest of people can't
procreate they will not be allowed AI
will find a way Terminator however you
want to call it a lot of people who need
to get this stuff together because AI
you're going to get an email going
you're done they won't let us have sex
no they will not because you know what
you can't be effective up next Dana
Perino is changing her name we will
explain after this I wonder Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now